have any animals out there get camels
rather you have a crack team ready for
this kind of nonsense
[Laughter]
the golden eagle they that's their
mascot the golden eagle is also a gay
dude that's never been with a woman
[Music]
coat is cold for that you know that
right is that is that that's really a
term
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
you're sitting by me bucky i thought you
were there with brendan huh you and
brendan i'm just
would be good
but then eric's out
[Laughter]
so this is
the story that's the story of my life
so why still
aren't you supposed to be sitting there
huh you're supposed to be sitting there
no
what's going on got laid off man what's
going on this is you're king of the
sting this is we're just we're just
switching the dynamics yeah i just
sometimes like being a guest better than
i like being in the host seat
[Music]
honestly bro can you relate to that or
not you think i still want about what
we're talking about i still want to yeah
yeah man you can just film it you know
yeah
you think it takes spotlight
i don't like being in the driver's seat
show starts showing up
takes off the load off your chest yeah
that's what we should do then we should
like plan it out and then
take the time to do it
i can king from over here hey man i
faltered it looks great oh those are too
rough man this is real tobacco no i know
it's too rough that'll stop your legs
and you've got that'll stunt your growth
too bub well i mean i think i think that
ship has sailed
yeah he's 50. it'll also make you 10
races yeah that code that kodak is this
dude i've never seen
yeah what theo had never
[Laughter]
but she
like a baby bird
i'm just scared if i'll get sick or not
that might make you sick these won't do
will it make my heart start to hurt or
no not at all your dumps might hurt this
won't this won't hurt that will hurt
your gums this won't hurt anything
i just don't want to get they don't
really have racism in them do they no
all right i'll take one he's like i
can't have any more
yeah
he's like i'm full of people
i got
[Laughter]
all this is good this little setup right
here
all this is going to do is bring all the
trolling on me
why why yeah that's what i'm saying
yes it will they're going to be like i
already get like i hear
well
yeah they're going to say that in the
comments like dude
griffin you know where's steel that's
actually me in the comments
[Laughter]
sometimes
it's the two of us doing it on that burt
one i got comments people are like oh
this is called thank goodness yeah i'm
so sick of griffin why are you reading
that [ __ ] no no because i'm tagged
but still but it just pops up you just
you know you're looking forward to he's
getting are you really
really getting hate no he's not it's not
real hate though hate is when somebody
comes to your domicile or home somebody
has a weapon somebody has a sword
something no they could do that in dm
feels right huh they do that in dm if
you give them the power
but you have the ability to not do that
messages you have oh yeah i'm sorry man
that's okay damn you you gotta hate
stevie yeah yeah
about what stevie
my parents should have aborted me
um holy [ __ ] but that's more like time
and kind of stuff i feel like just all
this is the worst [ __ ] yes what are you
laughing at man i'm just i'm just the
the theo's thinking process i'm just i'm
getting on that
you and yeah you know what i mean they
don't like us no they like you guys
together the comments when it's just me
and him are [ __ ] horrible what are
you talking about it's all like this
these guys
this is your thing dude there's nothing
but love for you this guy looks like a
livestock this guy looks like uh no what
they used to say brennan looks like the
kind of guy that rides on on a horse
with both legs off to one side
is that a compliment though i don't
think
see this is something that they control
you about steve creating more issues
than there are issues here yep what are
you talking about so you guys please
troll that i was i was stevie i was the
solution i saw you did a podcast with
your brother finally got him on oh yeah
finally huh yeah the guy sees you
getting a little cloud over here and he
finally freaking monkeys you up there oh
you know what he said to me though it
was funny what do you say he said he
can't stand where people go uh that he's
steve's brother
hilarious
oh
you've always been the cuter brother
anyway though no but i've always been
known as bob's little brother have you
and who's old are both of y'all no he's
older than me
famous for a hot second though what are
you talking about you know what i'm
talking about yeah i know you're talking
yeah no it's tough can you have him
maybe give him some encouraging talks
about maybe losing some weight yeah is
this peach flavor
uh lemon doug is limited
yeah he's got a lot he's got a big he's
got the buddha belly now really oh
the success belly yeah he eats nothing
but b barbecue i think really yeah come
on you guys are acting like you don't
know but dude it's just called barbecue
dude korean bbq korean bbq yeah but
maybe is he doing for a roll or
something no he orders dude he orders
frozen pizzas from like chicago and
stuff and they deliver you know those
thick
pizzas i know exactly my mom used to do
it for christmas if somebody's mailing
you if somebody is mailing you pizza you
are fat yeah yeah yeah i admit it i'm
gonna say that and that i don't mean if
anybody is fat i'm not talking about
yeah i'm coasting who does this i own it
have you ever because you're former
you've you've been fat before you've
been fat yeah some would say stone but
yeah and have you guys ever had like
specialty foods mailed to your home
exact pizza that bobby did i did every
christmas dude remember them larry and
david pears or whatever they would say
what's that i wasn't in this is when i
was young dude it was a close ever came
to homosexuality was when larry and
david pearse would show up at christmas
oh is that is that the the like the the
[ __ ] and you open it up and they got
six little pears in there and i think
they're from real pears like the fruit
pears oh yeah okay i don't and i think
they're from an orphanage or something
they're good
lips juicy [ __ ] with me yeah juicy
pencil too
okay that's so juicy bro
they should have their only fans bro
they are afraid
[Laughter]
there's a lot of women that love you
doing what aren't only fans just being
you
well like just being at home and looking
at you no theo that's an ass i mean you
know king somebody doesn't have the only
fantasy
yeah it's called a podcast
it's called king of the stink yeah
i think there's some dudes making money
on only fans right probably not as much
as the lady yeah but be fit though right
i think it's more for like uh game maybe
i don't want to say like gay men or
people with animals maybe i don't know
like uh like uh pets
porn show your pets like a home animal
meet the male sex workers the only fans
he dude yeah there you go oh it's a
black guy yeah my body doesn't look like
an orange whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
oh see this guy's making money that's
renee from the company's relationship
parks cars
you know him yeah
yeah
for sure you know i one time
look at this guy well that's kyle my
videographer
oh damn kyle first cat now you man so
this guy's our only fans
apparently dude
god they're making oh i told you you
need a rottweiler that one makes sense
this is what it is it's guys with ptsd
hugging animals and that's how
he's been in afghanistan or something
like that and now he's
and i'm ready to go fam i'll tell you
that you know that yeah
case we get drafted dude and his name is
stevie okay don't say it don't call him
that what what he's trying to call him
his traditional starting with guys over
40 in the draft huh they're not going to
talk
they might be too old i'm most likely to
get drafted out of this group
no no no no no i'm too short you need to
be over you're in height though you're
too short and there's alright no you
could play the drum now
you would be at the mess hall the guy
like that angry guy with the spoon out
of the tank like like the yeah like the
guy who feeds the child yeah i don't
qualify man and he would be like good
morning vietnam he'd have him at the
radio station just telling dumbass
stories to the troops
just entertain the troops
like if we're in 300 you're the guy with
one eye that when they're about to go to
war he's like you go back and tell the
stories yeah and he's like no man
you know that's that yeah that's you
doug i'm keeping moral bro that's mine
you're the storyteller
you think you why would you think you
would get drafted theo cause [ __ ]
look at me you're fit too huh yeah i am
looking touch my arm see yeah you're
pretty muscular
yeah i don't know if military is for you
bubba yeah oh dude i get up at a decent
hour have you ever thought about joining
the military though i thought about it
yesterday for about almost 40 minutes
with the marines or army like what what
i'd go air force dude i'd kind of wander
no that's not for you you're not you you
fly you give me a grunt in the [ __ ]
front lines in the army man there's
women in the air force though dude
marines you have to pretend people are
women
yeah i got to go i would have to go
right into like middle management you
know i can't just you won't be on that
you'd be a contractor i think yeah you
know what i mean i just i can't go right
to
i was you know the military if i wasn't
playing sports that was the plan my
family's all military
the only time i seriously thought about
joining the military and honestly took
like a 40-minute think about it was
on at 9 11.
you know i really i
had the thought in my head i was like i
can't believe this happened and i had
that moment of like should i join the
military yeah you know did you just walk
outside and punch a muslim or would you
no i uh i don't know i just thought like
that
but did they do it do we know who did it
yeah
we still don't know no we know
they said it was saudi arabia no we know
i mean i'm just saying like we like now
there's all this thing we pulled out you
know like after 20 years we were
supposed to be training them this is
that we spent billions of dollars
trillions trillions of dollars for
training to get them ready and they got
taken over four days where's the money
we should get a reimbursement
with the taliban
all the tanks and guns the taliban was
like cool thanks for for all this cool
[ __ ] and so you're saying they took them
over in four days
where's the training man yeah dude yeah
these people was talking about
reparations
we need that money back we need a refund
i don't understand
i don't know all the politics of it i
don't know all the details of it all i
know is we've been in there for 20 years
preparing them for this and then and
then four days
well the bigger problem then we can move
on the big problem with the taliban run
in afghanistan is you know they're the
cover for all the terrorists like al
qaeda
al qaeda isis now they're going to be
able to grow here's a couple of them
right here dude this is also a
the life factory has this night i've
seen it before they're just chanting
death to america but they seem friendly
at the same time
dude
every now and then it's not friendly
look
red rover red rover y'all can have that
[ __ ]
i'm sick of this kind of [ __ ] man
this is the kind of [ __ ] that like make
you start a cell back at home people at
home be like oh we should do that here
over here
in akron
you know should we get into a debate
club yeah powerful joke as long as we
that we we're we're solid on the fact
that i would be drafted i think who
would get draft out of us
all the way no way
the guy shows up with a musket and a
knife and rubber you're like [ __ ] it's
2020.
he's gonna be trying to talk to him
first let's everybody settle down all
right everybody be cool man be cool man
you gotta go you gotta send us you gotta
set a rough rider in bro brenda
you ever been a long conversation with
that dude bro
he fit at three or four sentences in bro
he [ __ ] zones out man you know that's
nothing to do with fighting though
that's what i'm saying
but it ain't fisticuffs man you know
what i'm saying this dude will start a
podcast in the [ __ ] foxhole
who are you john wick all of a sudden
for real oh my back quinn teard like
what the [ __ ] you talking about y'all
[ __ ] ain't prepared dude you would
probably get drafted by the other group
what do you think y'all ain't even
[ __ ] you dare you switch teams no yo
i'm the only one that could get away
with that if we start losing i'm like
i might me too though i put that scarf
on yeah oh one high towel and these
[ __ ] slimmed out bro
i'm sneaking right out of there
pointing right at this steel
right there
bro you know two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 yeah half most of the
people in the studio do this true man
something shitty here up in here i'll
say this though that more than 50
million men in the us suffer from male
pattern baldness mpb thank god for keeps
they offer a simple stress free way to
keep your hair man it's low cost
treatment start just ten dollars a month
man
discreet little package comes to the
crib your girl don't have to know you're
trying to keep them locked well one
thing that i didn't like is if i was
trying some medicines and stuff i had to
hide them or i had to sneak them in the
house it's embarrassing doug and i have
to be nervous when i buy them at the
store like oh it's from my cat or
something the guy's like you don't have
a cat
it's not good dude prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast if you're
ready if you're ready to take action
ready are you i'm so ready all right
baby but if i take this stuff my shit's
gonna grow into my forehead really dude
i have a small forehead i'd bring it
down a little you could get another half
inch down you think i think so yeah i
would get some hair transplant or i
would just get some keeps if you're
ready to take action and prevent
hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash k-a-t-s to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
k-a-t has to get your first month free
keeps.com
cats man i'll tell you this one thing
that i like that grubhub is doing man
and i know you
definitely have eaten a good bit of your
day and that
they are doing this thing where they're
supporting good restaurants by
delivering the food exactly the way the
restaurant serves it man i've worn
something from some places not grubhub
oh they've thrown in the yard yeah yeah
i ordered i ordered one time it was uh
um i ordered i think it was like a
rack of lamb or something they delivered
it in an omelette oh you were rich rich
they delivered it in an omelette it
doesn't come in an omelette but now man
how about what they're doing with panera
i know your fat ass like some carbs man
yeah panera they're doing a little extra
with panera get free delivery perk on
your first order from panera 15 or more
all you gotta do is order through the
grubhub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants yup grubhub works hard to
serve restaurants so they can work hard
to serve you especially in during
pandemic times you don't want your good
restaurants going out of business
so go through grubhubs
man we serve restaurants all right what
do you got nick what up king of the
sting it's kyrik back at it with another
debate club
so we just had a pretty progressive week
in the entertainment industry and i want
to know who you're more proud of we're
more proud of matt damon for stopping
his usage of the f slur or
are we more proud of britney spears for
getting on that uh that sticky
conservatorship with her pops you know
what i'm saying all right gang gang was
buzzed
she got out of it she got out of her dad
but here's the thing is so she's in
control of her own life now no there's
gonna be a new guy that comes in but she
gets i think gets to pick like the new
guy coming in what because the dad was
just like hey do shows i'm taking all
the money oh here's the man
picking what slave you know owner you
want a little bit my thing is like in
the court of law like obviously she has
some mental [ __ ] going on like the law
is just not gonna give somebody power
over you like oh yeah she shaved her
head something's going on we don't
i'm more proud of matt damon i guess
this is why celebrities don't do [ __ ]
interviews and podcasts and stuff like
why he you know he's jason bourne so you
never see him on a podcast and he's like
yeah i used to use the f term in a
joking way and then my daughter you know
got all mad at me so i stopped using it
and everyone's like oh cancel matt damon
yeah so he's grown like he's leaving so
he has some growth in his life boston
isn't he it's the boston national anthem
the f-word
it's in there
i mean
they put that in every song
we wish you were married
i don't know
i just think that you can't have some
personal growth without people getting
on your case isn't what they so should
he just still say it so he should just
say it all the time now if it's going to
get this
canceled my thing is is if you're gonna
cancel that person for saying that word
or someone who says something like that
so you think that's gonna help them
they're gonna get worse yeah you know
what i'm saying like if you tell that
person oh you've said that you're off
the island you think they're gonna get
less racist yeah they're gonna be
[ __ ] pissed but they're also kind of
free now it's like once you like oh okay
you know i say it good i'm in yeah yeah
let me drop a couple here here and here
one arrow one everywhere a little uh
yeah
you know
but that's why celebrities are only
doing those podcasts man they get in
trouble this is one thing you thought it
was like a fun story about family fun
and entertainment i thought you know
maybe robin being bisexual would be
better than uh but we knew that right
like i knew robin was a little
robin always had sugar in his tank like
no kid growing up was like man i
wouldn't be robin never well also his
eye things there was no if you look at
it the early way there's no holes he's
just a blindfolded little thot running
around little [ __ ] man you know what
i'm saying dude he was obviously used
for sex but he's a little twink man
anybody is a billionaire you know what i
mean yeah anybody that shows up in a
cape blindfolded and tries to run after
you and give me a sexually assaulted
looking for a gang bang
yeah so britney or
well here's the thing i think the only
way her dad even could still be a part
of her life
he came in later too theo remember this
she got super famous he was never around
as a kid well what's the situation like
management like i don't i'm good he
controlled everything her money her
income i didn't know that uh her cell
phone like she got all crunk on
instagram because she got a [ __ ] ipad
but he controlled everything and that's
why she stopped working i don't know
brendan that sounds and you don't
believe him either and this sounds look
it up huh chin knows the story hashtag
free brittany you stupid [ __ ] i know
about free britney but she didn't get
she has millions of ipads brendan
you can't believe it on her instagram
she was crunk over the one ipad man so
she never had technology
i don't know she came to her kids
she could see her kids do k fed that's
the kids
they must have cut the eye holes out in
this image bro and look at this one i'm
not saying this but the dude on the left
watch what you say watch what you say i
don't know what you know what i'm saying
say something adam east bro if you look
at the dude on the left
east yeah he's a little too much rouge
dude
bring up back that pitcher man we ain't
done with these
guys what do you have to say that dude
is great don't they yeah they do look
like great men but i'm just saying it
looks like a gay couple the guy on the
left
man with the bat on his chest and with
the blatantly asian no they're not asian
man
what's wrong with that man nothing's
wrong it's wrong okay eric you telling
me this guy ain't asian bro no they're
not with the battle i'm looking at robin
little the schumacher uh batman's you
know he we had the nipples on the uh the
uh the suit yeah heavy nips yeah that
was like he's asian man no no they're
the white guys and with that wuhan
symbol on his chest look at his chest no
man come on
yeah dude that's that freaking
international uh
appetizer man they're serving that to
everybody down there you are right there
stevie with your brother finally
spending time with that and how you
never got to it
how was the pod was it were you guys
friendly with each other yeah of course
of course i just haven't spent a lot of
time with them you know he's been busy
yeah dude so it was good seeing him yeah
i'm worried about his health though i
really like he's so heavy yeah dude he
needs to does he acknowledge it or he's
like nah i'm good
he doesn't even
ask eric i mean have you brought it up
to him
yeah
yeah i wouldn't get their podcast and it
was like well because my i get cause
he's on the belly he's cause he's
calling me fat you know that's the big
joke and who's fat out of you too you
know
per capita
yeah i think gary looks like he's in
good shape when i saw you today you seem
like he's in good shape that's 40 better
[ __ ] man did you really 40. 40 pounds
damn is your girl like damn daddy yeah
mm-hmm she must be happy you know what i
mean
i'm tossing around
putting pepperonis on her back
[Laughter]
have you been doing them specialty foods
like what you know like
it's a little box it got to nine
calories
like food um
like the prep yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
i love having are you using like
sunflower or anything like that i use
sun basket you know what i mean and you
can get 40
40 off
listening to this man that's why y'all
wouldn't get drafted bro cause y'all
don't [ __ ] listen the colonel will
want y'all to listen
y'all get shot
what war are we going to do
afghanistan's over huh is it did you see
the commercial a minute ago yeah we're
out
but we're gonna have to go back but i
think we're gonna have to go back yeah
and it's actually a way to prove that we
should still be there it's like
everybody's like what are we still doing
there okay pull out and then we're like
get them back there that because like
it's it must be difficult for people who
are very progressive liberal to deal
with this because it's like what they're
going to do to the women there now yeah
they can't you know what i mean and now
that these are the ones that are like no
war no war we're like okay pull them out
now it's going to be like you want to
help these women now
because that takes troops money and
fighting yeah so and i'll see they can
which one you want
and i'll see they can't fight yeah
clearly therefore
taliban only had i think they said 30
000 uh like troops against their 300 000
those 25 000 people
who were like yeah we training them you
know what i mean yeah
yeah we're training them and it's just a
bunch of barry's boot camp over there
it's a crossfit yeah
it's like a crossfit
[Laughter]
facts all the details we just some
comics talking about the [ __ ] you know
before you like it doesn't feel right no
it doesn't it don't feel that's when
they took over four days common sense of
it to me when i heard i was like because
wasn't it shocking to know that we've
been here for 20 years yeah i wasn't
it's almost like britney spears
conservative ship i was like that [ __ ]
been in that [ __ ] for 13 years i wasn't
even thinking about it so i'm like wow
we've been over there 20 years since
bush and and then you go okay we're
training uh we're doing all this stuff
we're making sure that they can take
over and they'll be fine then we're like
okay the one president comes in like you
know what i'm tired of this war pull him
the [ __ ] out and then in four days damn
but but even biden was i i didn't think
it'd be this yeah he was yeah he was
like god damn damn show a little pride
fellas like god damn it's like they
can't fight for their own country why
are we doing it yeah and then you know
it's bad because did you see the
american plane taken off and they're all
hanging on to it and then yeah it takes
off and the dude falls yeah i saw that
video
that was real that was real have you
ever missed a flight though it [ __ ]
sucks dude
[Laughter]
yeah because you got to get your show
you're going to meet me
trying to get the buffalo yeah that was
the dude falling on it that was real
well is it real some people are saying
that's fake
what people said that they edited that
the dude jumping out of the same people
he didn't jump over his face
it is obvious what happened eric you're
right jumped out no he fell he jumped
out of the plane he fell off he fell off
oh my god what was his thought you gotta
have upper body strength he's gonna take
a fight like that he realized this ain't
gonna go well well he might he was it on
the runway he was like i got this he
might have thought if i hang on they're
gonna stop me oh this [ __ ] taking off
oh god and then 700 miles an hour like
oh hell no and then that's why you got
to work out on those what is that
vibrating plate thing that you did do oh
i know what you're talking about
oh he could have stayed that's gonna
help you stay on a [ __ ]
b52 bomb
dude if you did that for probably two
hours a day but you could probably take
i bet you he'd make it a couple hundred
miles yeah but i agree eric they
basically they must have trained these
dudes at home
it's not gonna help you man that that
vibrates exactly yeah whole body
vibration this is the training
and then they sent the invoice and i'm
saying and they sent the invoice yeah
and the invoice was like 800 000 and
they were like for what
you know we yeah
dude
look yeah they train these [ __ ] at
the orange theory right
with a tripwire section no what's the
one they said these [ __ ] are in shape
but they can't fight what's the name of
that gym that's always next to like a
applebee's you know plant business no
it's not planted fitness that's the
saddest place it's like a lot of women
go to it you know
scarves curves curves yeah curves is
always next to like a chilis
it doesn't make sense
the other day
oh man dude
yeah that's where they train them at cuz
i don't get anyways but maybe you know
i'm pretty sure people in the comments
are already uh going off about like no
this isn't live man like they [ __ ]
know yeah i don't know yeah if you're
fans of this show you know we need some
militarios to maybe call in and give us
some guidance i think
tim kennedy are calling for sure i can
call timmy i think a lot of military
people though what do you already feel
like we they they that this was going to
happen right like if you were over there
you know that they ain't you know yeah
they know what somebody's watching
they know you know when your truck
drives off and there's three dudes out
there they're playing dice outside of a
subway you know these [ __ ]
gonna get tucked down yeah so they knew
they were like if we leave this is
what's gonna happen i think a lot of
people military people felt that way and
here we are at the same time probably
feeling like why are we here but maybe i
wanna yeah i wonder what like real
military guys say yeah
we should be back there man they're
[ __ ] all this work and we've lost like
lives over there so it's like for what
if you're just gonna dip out why why'd
these guys put their lives on the line
you're seeing a difference it's very
political too though man well it's the
age-old story that why do we go to all
these countries i feel like and try to
ins and it's our duty and put our will
it's our duty i'm not saying it isn't
but after this after seeing how this
works if this is really what's going on
it's a lot of this could be actors bro
but after hey eddie bravo take it easy
they ain't active bro that one group
looked like a uh the only actor was that
white girl being like they're saying
kill americans but it's actually pretty
lit in here
yeah that's true
so weird she's obviously gonna get up to
she's over there to get some [ __ ] at
some of that sam wiener you know that
that lady
she ain't trying to
learn us
get that dirt serpent
yeah sand wiener
you bro do you see the video they got
one dude's hollering out of pulling at
the back of her little ak-47 trying to
holler at her
yeah man this [ __ ] is crazy she's like
they're even allowed to talk with the
taliban takes over women can't talk man
[ __ ]
so i'm thinking if one of us went over
as a colonel you couldn't go you could
you get the drum oh yeah or he flies the
drone i could do that yeah but they from
here like a video game i could do that
we have to disguise the drone as a bird
or something they will not like it yeah
a bird or you know fake put fake wings
on a drone like an american eagle drone
no
american eagle would get done down
immediately you need afghanistan
warbler or something yeah you need
something that they're going to see and
be like oh that's one of ours he's got
sand vulture is there ophelia is there a
national bird in afghanistan yeah what
is there nick
you guys think do they have any animals
out there they get camels whether you
have a crack team ready for this kind of
nonsense
[Laughter]
the golden eagle they that's their
[ __ ] mascot the golden eagle is also
a gay dude that's never been with a
woman
[Music]
this coat is cold for that you know that
right is that is that that's really a
turn thing
[Laughter]
i'm doing that bro
and you're gonna get it again unless you
start
honestly maybe stevie's like the comfort
animal we're just tickling [ __ ] after
war
we come back
and wrestle you up
he's in the barracks yeah and the boys
are like
you used to wrestle oh yeah no way
yeah bob did too yeah this dude got
medals and ribbons
dude there was nine people at that high
school no no no they're known for the
wrestling program and you know they
really get up
stevie you were in a singlet yeah i was
yeah did you did you do the andre the
giant just i feel like i had a moment
though i had your hair cut in high
school oh [ __ ] yeah yeah we need to see
pictures of this no we did we i i that
power flow yeah send it send it to nick
yeah you had that [ __ ] power mullet
out the back yeah i had the rat tail
yeah in 1991 oh yeah they had it then
that was popular then it came with a lot
of everybody had it
and it meant you were really getting
some leg too back then i was i was i
went to church camp and you know did the
bible study thing yeah wow without
seeing your body
you think i'm not getting laid
i could have a baby by now
can you text me that picture
i'm trying to find it while he finds do
you want to play this one oh here we go
oh damn that's quick all right here we
go
now bobby has a mullet too right right
now doesn't he is this peach flavored
lemon gosh damn it that's you bro yeah
dude that is um
damn
now eric this has got to be offensive to
you halfway wow
and he was black in high school
dude what were you drinking
cause i got
were you drinking chicken dude
did you eat all the eel that day why are
you so blocking it
right yeah
dude those ten those are those clucking
needles
well especially now we know you got
these black roots bro
you play the saxophone i went to the
beach a lot that's why you be the lisa
simpson of the day of war
that's you stevie
eric do you think man i like thinking
about this stuff because it's like do
you think the military do you think that
people really are like
do you think they feel like they were
used kind of
i don't know if they think they were
used i think when you join the military
you you know you you right you sign up
for whatever whatever their thing is but
i think that like you know you want you
want it to have a purpose so it's like
okay we'll go do this and we're told
it's for this a and then it's like after
20 years you're like okay
what is the purpose of this but they can
also see what's going on there the
people that got their foots on the
ground they see what's going on right
they know how people are being treated
they know that if they like they were
already saying that some of the military
were already saying like hey we got to
help the people that helped us get out
of there because it's going to be
retribution on those people from the
taliban yeah you know so they know it's
like hey we can't just up and leave but
there's no good way to get out of this
probably just you know there's no like
easy transition and we left in the night
right we left like the damn indianapolis
colts baby we left or whenever we left
like the cleveland
theo looks identical to the guy from
metal gear solid right now you do bring
that [ __ ] up nick
you do you do identically
and then bring up the picture of stevie
that's going to get us canceled if you
don't mind we get stevie cancelled
oh that's you dude
definitely one of the greatest video
games ever yeah one of them is real hard
i can't get past the first fence the
game was tough that was something i
remember when i beat it i was so [ __ ]
cool golden eye was a tough game that's
a good game i saved it on hard oh yeah
it was a tough game all right on july
20th mvmt movement is celebrating their
eight-year anniversary by running a huge
site-wide sale if you
need a watch yeah good thing july 23rd
passes by but they're still celebrating
eight years anniversary so guess what
everything on the site is 28 percent off
28 off their best-selling watches blue
light glasses jewelry and so much more
man movement is going all out for their
eighth birthday this is their biggest
sale of the year take advantage of these
price points before they go that's right
talk about your mvmt products and what
you loved about them quality modern
watches for a fair price preach super
durable sunglasses with u
v rated polarized lenses you're like ron
burgundy if it's up on the board you
gotta read it and timeless styles maybe
their premium blue like glasses will
make you not only look great but
filter ninety percent of the most
intense blue light rays from your
digital screens dude get your mom some
blue light glasses man be lit yeah i'll
get her something don't miss mvt mvmt's
biggest sale of the year go to mvmt
dot com slash cats
28 off 80 off wow that's 28 off state
site wide site wide at mvmt.com
join the movement join the movement
hey brennan hey theo this is enrique in
nebraska here with my girlfriend
she could be a position
the baby
don't do that i know what you're doing
dude he's being me get the gat baby i
want a war you just said what does this
do one [ __ ] war bro let's start start
it over i'm so sorry
hey theo this is enrique in nebraska
here with my girlfriend save me
question for you debate club actually
should the man always drive or should
they take turns
personally in our relationship look at
him looking at her see what she what's
okay if i take my car
i drive gang gang
she's not happening dude that could be
bobby lee too his hair died off yeah
like like with a blow out is bobby it's
bobby with a blowout totally
totally what do you mean i don't trust
your old family you see that other black
picture you a minute ago yeah your old
family shape-shifter dude yeah a bunch
of [ __ ] well he was in star wars and
you know what i mean yeah a bunch of
taiwan transformers over here to your
whole family's [ __ ] shifting shapes
baby bunch of ewoks bro
dude this dip's making my eyes hurt a
little bit yes look at that wow
very similar
like if he saw bobby he want to smash
and not know why
he's just kind of feeling it
girl stop looking at me like that she's
in better shape than bobby i will say
that though
and she does have that brazil what is
that hair called chin highlight
her roots grew out though i'm trying to
let chin keep his job by saying
something okay nobody else wants to help
him the roots are going up
uh every episode
well i'm still scared finding out about
his past
remember he was in the asian gang when
you weren't here
oh you had an account at the bank you
were the front man but chin had a plan
to kill these dudes
and they didn't show up and jim was like
they lucky that we were like what i said
i was lucky if something happened that
would have been the end of everything
yeah but you're saying that you knew you
would have killed them
you're saying i'm yeah lucky that they
didn't show up because i would have shot
these [ __ ]
being locked up for life
feels a little nervous now you need to
stop talking [ __ ] you don't know who
you're working with
you don't know who you're working with
the people around me were strapped not
me oh you didn't have a gun no no we
need to send our troops to wherever we
wherever chin's from then you think that
that is gonna work in court like you
think like he was gonna be in the court
like listen i they had a gun
i was just with the guys with the game
and if they shot me then they had i'm
just a bookkeeper
basically like the untouchables remember
that movie oh yeah it was gotta be so
much such a movie great movie how great
was that movie it was good wasn't it
costner kevin costner
kevin cox should be called king and the
add
i know
i love it this guy's got a relationship
advice question wait we didn't even
answer the last guy's question who
should drive yeah what did that what did
that guy want the last guy should the
man always drive
i don't know i always drive yeah i
always drive too yeah but i like when my
girl drives sometimes i'm tired can you
drive no no but do you bug are you i
don't know
you bug your girl while she drives yeah
you bother her
you bother yeah i'm like you the
backseat driver yeah i'm like yeah i'm
like where [ __ ] you're going
i like that you know like how do you not
know where you're going and that's why i
drive other otherwise we'll fight i'm
like hey
go around why are you gonna stay behind
the [ __ ] giant truck go around [ __ ]
i also like to grab my girls titty while
she's driving yeah oh yeah oh yeah still
fun stuff yeah
do they constantly your significant
others constantly go
like when you're braking you're coming
up to a stop i'm like i see the car in
front of me like it's just constant oh
it causes a lot of oh my my chick is
always saying to me like you know you're
road rage you know yeah and all i said
was like what you doing you know like
that's
that's road rage to her that's a white
girl you're just white my girl yours is
asian yeah yep is that why you do all
the driving though
yeah that's what i'm saying
this all makes sense that's racist bro
is it though named the best [ __ ]
asian f1 driver got it i love it
hey back us up man that's a racist joke
man dude asians could drive rich coming
from you
chin back me up man race remember we're
racers right dude i'm defending our
country bro i'll tell you this if they
walked in here and picked one person to
fight right now for us it would be me
probably maybe because you're in the
fatigue why do you want why you want to
go to war all of a sudden yeah common
sense that would make sense
so someone would walk in and we would
say let's just say we said what we do
and what we used to do okay you think
they would pick you i used to do light
combat i would say
medium in the light even the wrestler
would be over you i'm about 35 yeah no
this dude yeah but you're nimble man
you'll be out here for lunch bro above
30 above 35 dude sleeps in a sardine can
this dude is [ __ ] like i think the
former ufc fighter and the ex-gangster
yeah around me this would be top two
it would go brendan but also diversity
hires you guys would probably get taken
or gianni since he's on power and we're
back
yeah gianni would probably get
black do you think you were gianni on
power eric
when watching his instagram he's a
little blacker
he be playing it up on his instagram
yeah
yeah
he's doing a lot of this yeah
i mean the baby up here
yeah man take it down the notch bro we
have to like he has to like get
de-blacked with it before he comes home
yeah yeah
he's like i have seen my children they
got a cinnamon
cracker barrel
just
just to like okay i'm back everybody
okay i'm back to regular yeah they sent
him to a pickleball court
just a real white [ __ ]
speaking of road rage did you guys see
this video oh yeah this is good who's
this and look at what he controls the
neck dude look how he controls this guy
he does it's just a random someone
caught some guys fighting after road
rage incident but you got to see the end
[ __ ]
take this dick that next girl
dude smart
knees
are you done is that americana brendan
yeah bro
yeah make sure you get my stuff thank
you
i think i appreciate it all right dude
that was weird see that's a game of
thrones [ __ ] man i love that that's in
colorado too probably i'll tell you
something yeah what was that what the
hell [ __ ] is what that meant that's man
[ __ ] he was like the guy was like you
know what you can beat my ass you got me
i'm tapping out sorry about what i said
i was like that's all i needed from you
respect that's all i know that's what
happened right there yeah praise god
and he said hurry up before the cops
come we don't want to get in trouble the
guy who got his ass beat yeah he was
like come on dude i'm not going to call
cause he's getting like he's like i
don't want to call you you got me are
you win this one let's move on all right
i'm not taking two l's i'm not getting
beaten up and having to explain to
somebody else oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i did some [ __ ] i was getting there
dude did y'all see speaking of this kind
of fighting [ __ ] that stuff that would
happen at the
ball game yeah at the rams game but how
about this though dude
no no but how about this the dudes fight
with everybody because he gets hit with
a beer and then you find out it's a fat
chick threw the beer from the back oh
that's what caused the scuffle you know
what i mean he gets it he's like oh hell
no i'm just trying and she's just like
and i'm like i can't stand that yeah if
you can't be in the fight
don't instigate the fight yeah get your
big ass in there girl you know because
then you can't get a gut punch because
now it's gonna be like oh you can't hit
the girl right but look look what
happened
this is the other side this is a
pre-season game what's happening
explain what's happening they're just
fight they're just dumb football they're
just drunk fighting they're cheering
there's a lot of white dudes in this
[ __ ] you can't see the chick throw it
but you see no there's another video
where you see it though no no it shows
it it's about from the behind
perspective now it came in and hit it
this isn't this isn't even the one man
that's not the big donald that was
another one it's like one guy and there
was a black guy with him too and they
were like scuffling with the people and
then the beer comes and then he's like
he starts he was doing well to his fat
ass slip dude
no
that's when you got to get down there
put him in the hard scarf lock him out
yup he's still doing jiu jitsu i [ __ ]
locked that dude out of his own life
are you doing jiu jitsu now
yeah
he's feeling himself yeah i'll challenge
y'all in two [ __ ] years idiots
in two years
yeah dude you have to get you have to
get to different levels watch this [ __ ]
she she's the one that's going to throw
oh there she is little birdie huh
look at her dress like a referee too
[ __ ] get out of here
i'm sorry but that just makes me mad
when women dress like authority figures
boom and then he thinks it's one of them
oh she did it yeah
oh there's another angle you can see
from and here's what i want to know why
are they all the same dude
yeah it's four of the exact same guys
why are they all this oh i see what
you're saying eric yeah she did it and
dipped he slips
some people pay good money for this well
i used to pay for 50 dude two vietnamese
dudes downtown put you in a dog bite
suit and beat the [ __ ] out of you son
how much was that 11 years ago is it 55
55 tipped them 60 bucks
but was there a happy ending oh i mean
he was happy to get out of there it
wasn't like his little
it wasn't like a little dog
avoiding the question but was there a
happy dude not like stevie's i never
came i had blood in my urine once all
right but i don't count that is it is it
coming
this guy is looking for some advice
that's gianni dude yeah what does he
have to say
obviously it's one of gianni's other
brothers dude
yeah there's so many
there's a lot of well there's so many
little dance
wasn't enough of a brother we got this
[ __ ] guy right here [ __ ] ink
gristle
atv
what do you do
when a chick slashes your tires
currently sitting in my car with two
slash tires this is the second woman
that's done it to me damn i don't know
if i got a beef with rubber or something
uh i mean both of them had abortions so
maybe that's not me
but you think i got uh
yeah king interesting in retaliation
somebody slashes your tires what do you
do
you go back and do it to them i mean the
[ __ ] is broke doesn't even have a car
so
i can't do that let's cut the sides of
her feet where do you take the high road
proper air max's dog or cutter what's
the back of your muscle in your leg
achilles calves
[Laughter]
um
this guy makes bad choices yeah yeah
he's meant to cut out the part with
abortions because he sounds like such a
piece of [ __ ] but just pretend that
didn't happen what do you do if someone
slashes your tires no they don't have
those chicks don't have cars so you can
pop the air maxes or something she left
out a lot of yeah we don't know her
yeah the key is like two women slashing
my tires like cause you probably [ __ ]
her sister you know what i mean he
doesn't sound like a great guy yeah you
probably forced them to you know you you
they maybe they wanted you to pull out
and you didn't
i have a feeling this segment of the
show is going to be played in a
courtroom
because
this guy gianni what's his name seems a
hell of a shame yeah [ __ ] as hell yeah
for sure
yeah what should we get some more info
like why did they slash your like for a
girl to slash your tires and the
abortions though maybe he didn't pay for
maybe he wasn't contributing to the
abortion oh well he contributed
something that's a good point
yeah do you pay for the abortion or do
you let them pay for it brendan
uh i feel like he should pay for it yup
we could pay for we could probably do it
for him
i think it's been done i think that that
ship has sailed
you want to get him some new tires too
how far you want to go for this piece
yeah you're right man let's get the lady
a bite yeah we need to find out who
these women are
i would love for them to be like come on
live and be like well this is what he
did and you know what i mean like this
guy's coming across like hey like and he
thinks that we going
his [ __ ] he did something yeah yeah
this guy's like hey guys they're gonna
get me killed some [ __ ] yesterday
he's like you believe this [ __ ] man two
abortions they slash my [ __ ] tires
this guy he could like this kind of guy
like send a message from jail hey what
up king of the sting
you know gang
correctional facility like [ __ ] off man
like this guy
unbelievable dude he's watching right
now being like [ __ ] those dudes
that's jesus baby and theo had to give
him money we already gave twenty five
hundred dollars to convicted felons
that's true actually one of the people
who started giving out money to these
convicted felons man forgot about that
he was like well man what we can do for
you is give you five hundred dollars
he's like thanks
guys he's like what
i'm a former drug addict man i'm not
gonna lie i'd buy drugs if i had more
money but it's just not in the place
where he feels like cool well we're
giving you a thousand dollars
and literally you saw a needle just fly
through the air right away
she all say less he planned it out
it was pretty interesting man it's
beautiful in here man
now that you can see you know welcome to
the podcast deal it looks nice well look
man
you know
just saying bro we got to protect
ourselves at all costs just like we got
to protect our country dude from these
fiends out there
this guy's gotta cater sting it
what up brandon steve bert
um
i gotta cater sting it so i work on the
road [ __ ] us mostly contrast ups
mechanic um
but that's not what it is my question is
would you just freaking chop rather over
here
live close to work
got that camper life you know what i'm
saying
and here's work
or as far away as possible and only come
in on your shifts
because then you got them guys banging
on your door hey
let me in
yeah i can't understand it
okay
um
[Music]
when when you park your house
next to your warehouse job
that's probably probably why
they knock it on your door or like
i don't i don't get this
yeah like hey uh you're obviously
stealing electricity bub yeah yeah okay
yeah and the wi-fi yeah yeah what's
going on there i think this is a good
guy he seemed like a good employee
though man he's willing to be right
there by work you got to really respect
that like he's just lazy you know that's
true you don't want to drive to work
doesn't want to walk to work yeah i mean
does he shower like i don't even know
so what was his question uh living close
to work and he lived really close to
work yeah i think he had asthma in that
rv that's too close to work that's too
close for me i think i was like you feel
like your break time though
yeah that's a good point you go on break
you go home get that napping
[ __ ] i'll be there for 14 minutes [ __ ]
okay
i'm getting all of that
like every second of that break
i'm standing at my door like this okay
and i'm back
[Laughter]
that's just crazy
i i like it then man in that sense i
like it and lunch you bragging and like
yeah you grilling bro
what's up y'all
they got their little lunch pails and
[ __ ] you out here with a [ __ ] elk
dude the worst with your lunch pail was
when you're uh therma so you guys have
the thermos you fill up with kool-aid
yeah when that spilled out on that
sandwich
bro yeah see what this guy has to say
[ __ ] hurt right yo what's up brandon
theo nick chin uh jimmy neutron or
whatever for that guy's name is then
troyer
uh coming at you from the back streets
of korea
waiting to harvest a couple of them
kidneys and had a quick kind of stinger
for you so be in english you can come
out to asia and teach that mother tongue
to the next generation
so
you know there's a lot of pros and cons
that comes with moving abroad
uh living in a new country
new cultures and that
so i was intrigued to see what you guys
think uh yeah i'd be interested to get
your input on that so can get stinger
teaching english in asia
i'm currently in korea enjoying that
soju barbecue
uh but yeah i know it's it's different
wherever you go just
let's see what you guys thought is this
guy trying to send us a message through
this message
i don't know um he can find a why teach
those kids that slang though man he
didn't have english slang well the first
word you teach anybody i feel like is
usually
customer f word n-word
um
yeah oh you're just skipping it what do
you think chin
only theo is going around yeah well he's
in korea this flow's in korea yes
that would be a great class you know
theo teaching the class
and he's got the words written on the
wall okay here's the n word
now you
what class would that be i mean look man
i'm just i think it's fascinating
if you meet somebody from another
country the first thing they teach you
is how to this dirty word dirty language
is true i don't see why this is like
there's nothing wrong with it yeah
that's what i'm saying i don't know why
he's even breathing in korea you know
what i mean this guy's bored obviously
over there
would you go back to your home country
and teach english when i was younger did
you i did yeah and what turned you off
at you think beautiful korean women man
really yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah honestly when i went come on my
parents told me all the time that
there's the most beautiful women in
korea and when i went two times i didn't
see that many people your parents are
lying and i saw a lot of girls with
cankles that's just what i saw what's
gingles candles what are they tangles
like those hats that kid rockies to wear
oh kingo are cankles
but okay but they have thick legs and
ashton no that was when you can't tell
the difference between the ankles
a lot of flat asses oh no a lot of girls
with shoulders over there too brother
cheeks go right into the shoulders bro
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
chin right into them
like damn oh it's dane cook
my name is jared and i'm from manchester
springs colorado and i had to king it or
sting it for you
basically i want to know how you guys
feel about toupees
no way this what brian callan needs
oh
what
bro his hair is terrible
wow dude that was better than a
quiet place too
that right there that was more
surprising than any movie i've ever seen
can i tell you something for a second i
was like good looking dude yeah and it's
like [ __ ] wow i totally get it put the
hair snapped the hair back on daddy
it look real he doesn't look like shimmy
he's a great looking guy he's brave
enough he's not like that like
four huh yeah before he looked like you
know he was like you know
uh they're affordable
and i i feel like just if anything
if people are gonna give you you know
the stereotypical things about it like
uh
like what's that dead ferret on top of
your head yeah he can get some people
but not really me um i prefer to have it
but i want to know what you guys think
well his hair is lit when he put that
wig on that [ __ ] is dope hell yeah dude
first of all takes that [ __ ] off it is
awful i like that he went for he looked
like a serial killer
like he was like
he looked like he looked like gianni for
a second
he just snapped that [ __ ] off and then
he took it off and he was like what up
it puts the lotion on it
you look like trevor wallace a little
bit man a little bit but now all i see
is the thing though bro but he didn't
unsee it but he didn't put it on good
yet though you know what i mean it's
like a tr when travis kelsey shaved his
beard he was in like gq and [ __ ] and now
that's him on the right holy [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
he should just shave it all off right
[ __ ] no no no you don't think he looks
better on the left
no no the other guy the other guy with
the two faces the other guy
that's not him
let's look at the picture then you guys
are just still out here on this what
let's look at the actual image it's not
that man
because you don't have the same feelings
in your life you're from dying against
the other [ __ ] piece man he looks
terrible that ain't him bro that's him
bro that's somebody's dad dude look at
the guy's body it's not even the same it
went from brendan to theo
[Laughter]
they also got a bad angle of them like
come on either way they said find the
worst picture of him you could possibly
find he just probably got off the field
yeah what
is fresh off the field the other
straight from gq yeah that's the other
thing he doesn't look like [ __ ]
he does look like [ __ ] and that one was
photoshopped they probably like fixed
his like lines and stuff come on man
they got those apps man
yeah when he snaps that [ __ ] i like
that better yeah he almost needs a
hitler mustache with that one right
there like a musician
yeah yeah yeah he could like a pumpkin
without that one he could get some alt
volvo with that
now can you swim in that thing
huh can he go swimming yeah you can
i'm telling you about have you seen oh
like okay so the white guy ones
once you sort of see him you're like
what the hell is that
but the black dude where they spread
they look like the pittsburgh steeler
helmet but it's like no no what it's
like because they use like glue and it's
like you can't even tell yeah you
wouldn't even know i feel like black as
you can tell more
when they like when lebron used the
spread oh that's different though that's
different that's different i'm talking
about if lebron is gonna do it right
yeah he would like you know shave it all
off and put on like oh it'd be like a
tight thing like steve holy [ __ ] yeah
you see what i'm saying look at that
put his head in the [ __ ] fight i
didn't even know yeah yeah that guy was
like you went from firehead to normal
man
that's the way to do it what did you
google right there that's hilarious
black fake hair what did you yeah
painted hair carlos boozer had like the
yeah boozer had that whole texture
that's stupid
yeah he could go to lebron his [ __ ] was
terrible then he had the headband to
cover it up yeah and then it started
falling off and his boy anthony dave was
like bro you're here because i'm all
[ __ ] up
he bought somebody's hair didn't he buy
that one homeless dude that dude that's
homeless now didn't he buy his hair
deonte wilder or whatever west vallante
west somebody said he bought his hair
and made him yeah delante [ __ ] his mom
huh yeah whoa that's facts what yeah
he's saying that yeah no that's real
well i mean
i mean is his mom look that's his mom
right there with uh mr west
yeah that's behind him see the the one
with the there is look at him what
that's on that boy's name lebron's mom
yeah
that's on lebron's mom for sure
she got a type obviously
[Laughter]
yeah i see it yeah i like his hair like
hell what the [ __ ] that wig oh no
he looks cool
i would say yeah
looks like a musician
black people can do more cool stuff with
their hair i think so you get they got
that they got their desires and [ __ ]
like what if theo revealed right now
that that ain't for real no i know it's
not real he just went he's off
it is his back hair in in the front yeah
that's true some of it is taken out of
the back and getting in the front i'm
getting more done he's the only person i
only get procedures and doesn't need it
he likes surgery
i love surgery
you're one of those you chill out have
you met you
something's wrong with you
[Laughter]
you like it i mean if i lost my hair i
would rogaine
rogaine is the worst dude
everybody might do rogaine and he grew
you know where he grew hair on his arm
[Applause]
no no he didn't grow hair he was taking
whatever that kind of stuff and it was
like he was growing here in places that
i don't need air here you're supposed to
be here
yeah he had uh cornrows on his hips
he had a philly fade on his back
when i was growing up we had a black
dude in our neighborhood and he had his
his he was like uh paraplegic or
whatever this you know this para i guess
and he
he had braided his legs around each
other and put a big fake barrette at his
[ __ ] knees bro
well it'd be weird if it was the other
way theo if like if he was paraplegic
from the waist up yeah but his legs were
working
he was just like this but the legs what
up
but he had his [ __ ] [ __ ] just right
just cornrowed his legs yeah
pretty cool i need to see pictures of
that
oh they didn't have pictures back then
man you have a drawing of it i bet
like it was a court what are you doing
you little sheep huh
john caparulo has a question
all right boys
what both of y'all can't understand
usually i like a little bit of you know
mainly protein in my meal we're gonna
protein bread potatoes mainly
um but every now and then i'm gonna go
ahead go with the girl
and uh
might get a little bit of appetizer a
little bit of soup a little bit of salad
action
this is a problem with america king
interesting it eaten extra if i want to
you can't understand it's soup should i
stay in korea it was a question like
order food should i order food just
getting soup and salad no that's gay man
no that's not what we need
we need some more hood [ __ ] king at
her stingers man this [ __ ] has gotten to
the point where it's like should i have
this steak or should i just have this
tilapia yeah yeah
we're seeing croutons on my side so you
have a lot of fans that look like this
guy yeah and you you then you like go
over and the chick is dope yeah like
let's see it again let's hear he's not
in la is what i'm saying because she
wouldn't be with him
[Laughter]
even she was like this is a dumbass king
or sting it yeah even she's like okay
i'm gonna definitely live with someone
else next time well she obviously
doesn't really like the show but she has
to deal with right because of him damn
you know what i mean she's got this
super salad she's a beautiful little
lady right there two eyes head
i love it now here's a very minimal
standard
got a set of ears on here
and this view
i'm in the vermin with the sermon i
already see that shirt that he's got on
baby let's go son what's up brendan theo
chappelle cat even though you guys fired
them chin nick b flips i got a king of
theirs and b flips
thrift shopping i've been thrift
shopping a lot more and sometimes you
find them secret hitters
but let me know what you think thrift
shopping king it or sting it gang gang
buzz buzz oh that's a king they got theo
shirts but like you know the teams that
lost the super bowl
[Laughter]
you know what they do with all those old
shirts all those old shirts they send to
africa because they print both of them
for the super bowl so there's a bunch of
kids in africa we're like god damn the
bills are [ __ ] dope dog they're doing
four years in a row
the rest of it also what ethnicity is
this guy let's figure let's get to the
bottom of this huh since we got a couple
of specialists here's a white mom black
he's puerto rican
he's no white mom black dad no no
that mustache comes in heavily french or
spanish
no it's just lionel richie vibe man yeah
when you was over did you ever go to
spain your family lived in spain didn't
they yeah i went to spain did you go
over there did you ever date any women
over in spain no no i just went to visit
my parents
you know what i mean but was there a way
to meet women like a meeting with mike
not where my parents were you know not
the country in spain it just was like it
just wasn't it wasn't set up it wasn't
set up for me to be like okay i'm going
out on the town you know what i mean
because then my mom would be like you
know oh okay you're not gonna spend time
with your mother you flew all this way
you know it wasn't a vacation
yeah
that's all we got
we should not end on that note though
this your crack staff
crap
that's true he don't even want to be the
talent anymore he's like you got one
foot out the door
he's supposed to be sitting right here
and he's like nah
let me check this out again
he
[Laughter]
i like being a guest sometimes it's fun
he likes to mix it up man yeah it's fun
being a guest i hope but i make you guys
feel bad about it no no no steve has a
real problem and it's fun having you
guys in here too it's fun i love the new
studio by the way really nice it's
really nice is that thick boy man yeah
this is uh good stuff i loved all four
of you energy is awesome we should do
this next two weeks if we can
yeah yeah i just i think it's fun i've
been watching the show with you guys on
it i really like it you do yeah what do
you like about i mean i don't really say
much he
because i don't feel like i could talk
over you guys are comedians i notice it
you know what i mean so i when you guys
do your thing i just want to chill no
you're great come on you're great i
notice it man you like that uh fish in
the tank that's like always over about a
little castle
you know you know he stays in the castle
everybody's eating he's just waiting for
the scraps
your little mermaid is what he's saying
okay okay you're balancing
that's not
who was the little mermaid ariel ariel
ariel but they got a new black one now
though
what do you say like that dog
that felt racist
[Laughter]
you got enough white [ __ ] no we don't
turn on any tv put chris mullen in space
jam all right yeah who would be in space
jack dirk
luca
look at the luca in a frickin space jam
then we'll talk man i'm just saying you
wanna you want a white jeffersons too no
but i would love to see a white amistad
a white amistad
a white django huh a white django i
don't know about that's phrases brendan
i would go home though i love that theo
has a line yeah come on man
too far brethren
look dude
when you see this kind of stuff it's
like okay come on it's almost like
that's what i'm saying it's like you say
all right really
like black annie's the one that got me
even black people were like we don't
want to do black annie yeah black auntie
is like come on she might be a dude but
you know it's not even just race stuff
man they doing this but all kind of [ __ ]
like i saw a huggies commercial and the
baby had glasses yeah
you know i like really
i wear glasses and i thought this was
[ __ ] yeah
that's what i'm saying i'm talking on
the road this weekend tonight i'm at the
uh um is it coming out thursday enough
time for people to go to the brea improv
no all right well never mind yeah
no i'm just doing one night the one to
thursday if they're across the street
they can maybe yeah they'll catch them
rush over 9 o'clock and i just i cancel
my north carolina shows but uh what
would happen
shenanigans well i'll tell you later but
uh well tell us now man we're here this
friday and saturday i'm at the hog la
the haha comedy club in la friday and
saturday two shows friday going back two
shows saturday i'm back daddy and then
next week i'm at my favorite place the
comedy store in la jolla thursday friday
saturday la jolla economy store but this
week friday saturday ha ha comedy club
come get some by the way i'm gonna be at
caroline's actually in uh in september
by the way i'm gonna be taking care of
my mental health if y'all need me bro
you know that [ __ ] and what else that
[ __ ] that ship has sailed ceo
you played that drum too many times yeah
i don't believe you yeah you need a
different drugs
coming back
my childhood
at some point you just got to accept who
you are even if everybody was like god
damn my dad was old it's like what the
[ __ ] have you heard this story already
surf is like we've already been over
this yeah yeah
we've been here y'all want to talk [ __ ]
i'll be at freaking war if y'all need me
dawg
you can find me tuesday through forever
in afghanistan baby [ __ ] kabul son
holding it down while these little
shape-shifters you know what i'm talking
about well these little [ __ ] thick
vietnamese freaks over here are over
here clowning around at rooney's chuckle
[ __ ] farm
[Laughter]
rooney's are you really careful you're
doing therapy yeah i am boys ain't
[ __ ] helping
man
all right love you guys man
therapy's
[Music]
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrage is thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn hungry
like i'm fresh off keto seeing red like
andrew santino every song i hit like the
great bambino brendan ate the queso and
the quesoritos but everything's gonna be
fine
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tripping couldn't beat
them quit playing like nintendo ds you
don't want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible brendan's son hit me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you